the Republican Presidential field is
descending on Iowa this week led by
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis last night
he held his first rally in the important
caucus State since officially entering
the race for the nomination a week ago
Ed O'Keefe was there and joins us from
Des Moines Ed good morning
Nate good to see you the governor has a
full day of events here across Iowa
before heading to New Hampshire and
South Carolina later in the week he
continues to Trail Donald Trump here and
across the country in part because the
former president is now relentlessly
attacking his one-time Ally but DeSantis
is no longer holding back
our Great American comeback starts by
sending Joe Biden back to his basement
in Delaware
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis kicking
off his presidential bid in Iowa by
vowing to make the rest of the country
more like the Sunshine State in Florida
we chose Freedom over falchism and we
are better for doing that
addressing several hundred supporters
the governor touted what he's done in
recent months restricting access to
abortion Services loosening gun laws and
banning state colleges and universities
from spending public funds on diversity
equity and inclusion programs in Florida
we didn't lead with merely words we
followed up our words with deeds and we
have produced a record of accomplishment
that we would put up against anybody in
this country DeSantis is now hitting
back at former president Donald Trump
who continues to lead the GOP field by
double digits the governor especially
taking issue with recent comments by the
former president who suggested the state
of New York run by democrats handled the
covid-19 pandemic better than Florida
yes the criticism is ridiculous but it
is an indication that the former
president would double down on his
lockdowns from March of 2020. while
Trump is also set to campaign in Iowa
today and Thursday so are other 2024
hopefuls who along with DeSantis are
attending a major GOP event Saturday
hosted by Iowa Senator Joni Ernst but
the santis has a big Advantage a Super
PAC already spending tens of millions of
dollars on ads in early primary States
and on reaching Iowa voters face to face
we look forward to your vote for
governor DeSantis in February Tim Hurst
is among dozens of people being paid by
the DeSantis Super PAC to go door to
door for the governor he's come from
Illinois to make the case it's time for
this to end I want I'd like to see all
Americans just be reunited again
now Tim told me he voted for Trump twice
but now believes that DeSantis can unite
the country and move us forward we'll
see if or how former president Trump
responds to the governor's remarks when
he campaigns here later today and
tomorrow Nate
uniting the country sounds good to me Ed
thank you